the mainline Pokemon games have evolved
graphically over the years but the core
mechanics have stayed the same catch
pokemon level them up and beat the crap
out of other people's creatures the
latest iteration in the franchise Sun
and Moon provides the biggest and most
welcomed changes to the series so far
and while it's story is subpar the core
ketchum all experience is as solid as
ever
one of Pokemon Sun and moons simplest
additions is also its most welcome the
game tells you what moves are effective
and ineffective while you're in battle
of course previous Pokemon games
improved systems and battle menus but
not as effectively as Sun and Moon after
your first encounter with a Pokemon
subsequent battles let you see how your
moves will affect your opponent but it
goes further you can see that same
information when you're swapping out
Pokemon to bring into battle finding out
what an attack does and how powerful it
is is as simple as tapping the eye
button next to each move and when you
want to try and capture your adversary
you can choose a pokeball to throat by
hitting a prominently displayed pokeball
rather than working through a series of
menus
whether you're a seasoned veteran or
completely new to the franchise Sun and
Moon is the most approachable Pokemon
game yet that's not called Pokemon go a
map on the lower screen of your 3ds
gives you an up-close detailed look at
the overworld and shows you where your
next objective in the story is located
in previous games trees rocks and water
were obstacles that your Pokemon had to
learn special moves to overcome but in
Sun and Moon you have a pager that can
summon Pokemon mounts to bypass those
obstacles on an artistic level Sun and
Moon is of triumph for the series along
with the refined battle system the
beautiful Hawaii inspired a Lola pops
with color the characters and Pokemon
have personality in their movements on
and off the battlefield the game
combines old and new Pokemon in settings
that feel natural and make each of the
game's islands feel like individual
worlds and Sun and Moon also changes up
the flow of the game you're no longer on
quite the same quest of finding and
fighting eight gym leaders this time
you're a newcomer to an island paradise
with various trials you have to overcome
and for Kahuna trainers to fight to
prove that you're the best in the region
these trials add variety to the
otherwise straightforward battling
mechanics in one trial you have to
gather ingredients for a simple cooking
game while in another you take pictures
at Pokemon the trials are more varied in
the beginning of the game than at the
end but it's still a welcome break from
tradition
for each of the trials you earn a Z
crystal which unlocks super-powered
abilities for each Pokemon type but as
exciting as it sounds the crystals
ultimately feel like an unnecessary
addition much like the trials themselves
they become less involved further into
the game and the rewards feel a lot less
special when other characters just give
the crystals to you where you find them
scattered around the world and while the
animations look cool watching the same
long sequences every time you use the
move is just tiresome even with battle
animations turned off the powerful moves
the crystals unlocks still involve over
long summoning animations choosing
effective matchups against your
opponents is generally a better strategy
than relying on Z boobs
zyy moves are an addition you can ignore
but unfortunately Sun and moons biggest
weakness is something you can't the
story Sun and Moon starts out strong but
the antagonistic team skull enemies are
one-dimensional and directionless and
the motivations of the central
antagonist who's revealed in a twist you
see coming a mile away
are just nonsensical the final themes
shift from a confusing diatribe about
cleansing the world to your enemy hating
their children for not being beautiful
before coming to an abrupt and
unfulfilled conclusion but then none of
this narrative matters anyway as you're
pushed back onto the route of becoming a
pokémon champion and the core collecting
and battling gameplay is where sun and
moon shines anyway as is standard in
Pokemon games once the credits roll
there's still a whole world left to
explore and new Pokemon to catch
while the main narrative feels
unfinished Ultra beasts are glossed over
and it's unclear how exactly Legendary's
fit into a lola's world there's at least
the opportunity to catch these rare
beasts and see the effects of unleashing
a portal to another dimension on this
peaceful island world the biggest
argument for Sun and Moon is that
despite the story problems I want to
stay in a lola and see how the game's
mysteries unfold now that I'm the
region's champion for better and worse
Sun and Moon offers the same Pokemon
experience that comes out every few
years but this finally feels like a game
that goes beyond the hardcore fans for
players who have loved or been
interested in the franchise before but
who felt that the growing roster and
feature set made the series too
unapproachable Sun and Moon is a great
reintroduction to a long-lost friend